I'm dr. Sam Raider I'm a licensed
clinical psychologist and I'm going to
be answering some of your mental health
questions
[Music]
in my understanding personality isn't
something you're necessarily born with
it's something that gets shaped through
early experience we learn what parts of
us feel acceptable in our family system
what parts of us feel unacceptable and
we adjust all the parts of ourselves to
shape into a personality that's going to
fit in our family system and what I do
as clinical psychologist is I help my
clients look at their personality for
example if someone's really shy we try
to understand what that's really about
and see if we can find more confidence
[Music]
clinically speaking something becomes a
disorder when it starts really getting
in the way of you being able to function
as a person in relationships at work
then yeah it might be some kind of
anxiety disorder and you might want to
seek treatment otherwise if you're able
to have a fairly normal life but big
waves of anxiety come now and then all I
can say is join the club
it's normal to have some anxiety
sometime it's really great though to
have some practices to know how to
self-soothe when you have that anxiety
I'm just gonna go with no how about not
talking about my friends with my friends
you know how much better it feels to not
gossip so yes the sacredness of
protecting the confidentiality of my
clients comes first and I'm learning
from that how sacred it might be in my
life outside of here to keep confidence
in friendships when tears just spill out
for seemingly no apparent reason my best
guess at why that's happening is that
maybe feelings have been held inside too
often when we go for days or weeks or
months with not expressing ourselves not
reaching out when we need help not
getting enough hugs sometimes we can
fill up like a bucket and when that
emotion bucket gets all the way to the
top the water is gonna spill out and
that's gonna spill out in the form of
Tears sometimes even when it makes no
sense why we're crying
there's so much less of a stigma around
depression now it's probably safe to
tell most employers if you're suffering
with it especially if that will help
them understand if things are changing a
little bit in your work style there's no
shame in asking for what your need and
ultimately your employer if there's
someone who's a good business person
will be really happy that they know
what's going on because then they can
help support you in continuing to do
good work
[Music]
well whoever you are I adore you and I
agree with you completely touch is so
healing I have a lot of answers to this
question the first is that maybe even
massage is enough for you who really
knows how to hit all those sweet spots
in terms of traditional therapy is often
frowned upon to touch your clients there
is a style of therapy that's really
wonderful called somatic experiencing in
one of the types of somatic experiencing
touch is used as part of the therapy so
somatic experiencing is basically
sitting sensing into your body noticing
what you feel where and allowing the
body to heal itself whether it's trauma
or pain emotionally or physically
[Music]
question has a lot going on inside of it
I have taken many many clients who swear
up and down they have incurable
depression and we get them feeling
better if there's a way to latch back on
to life there's a way to come out of
depression but if you have a stubborn
depression I encourage you to keep
fighting for wellness we've all been in
those dark moments it's just a state of
mind because you are loved you are cared
about and that somebody wants to hear
from you today if you're struggling with
suicidal thoughts what people imagine is
going on in therapy is that it's got to
be very clinical and there my doctor and
I have to sort of not tell them what I'm
thinking and feeling about them most of
the work that I do with my clients is in
the transference which is the
relationship between myself and the
client so if a client came in and said
hey this isn't working for me I don't
like the way you're doing this I would
think yeah jackpot we're really gonna
get somewhere because if we're able to
talk about our relationship what's going
on between us how it feels what they
like about what I'm doing what they
don't like about what I'm doing this
might be the beginning of a really
exciting time of growth with your
therapist so if all else fails and
you're really sure it's not a match for
you you can just let them know and say
thanks for our time together I'm clear
that you and I are not a match I wish
you all the best and this will be my
last session today I think it's so cool
that we live in a time where people are
becoming more and more aware of mental
health
there are countless self-help books out
there resources on the internet even
apps that can help you with depression
and find ways to get back out into your
life have real genuine experiences share
your feelings laugh dance sing cry this
is life a lot of clients ask me if it's
possible to change and in my experience
the answer is absolutely yes
[Music]
Wow